- So eight years off, right,
from doing like films and stuff.
- [Meg] Yeah.
- So, why that?
I appreciate that,
'cause even in the music world,
it's nice to have a break.
- Yeah,, I didn't try, I just,
I've basically just been hanging around.
I mean.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Like talking to my
friends, raising my kids,
like redecorating.
- I know, that's the important
thing, too, though, yeah.
- And then during COVID,
the script came to me
and I was like, oh, I've
always wanted to write,
I've always wanted to write a screenplay.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So that's what happened.
It's a movie, basically
they're locked down
in the movie together
and we were locked down at the time.
- Yeah.
- And I had all this time to write.
- What a perfect movie to
do in the lockdown time.
- [Meg] Exactly.
- Because it's really y'all.
- Yeah.
- It's just us.
- I mean, I think you probably thought,
well, you didn't know how long
the lockdown was gonna last.
So, it was a movie that you
could have actually shot
during the pandemic.
- That's what I mean, yeah, yeah.
- There's just two of us, that's it.
That's all.
- Except for all the people
that were actually in the airport.
- Except for the, yes, the extras.
- But we're the only ones who talk.
- They're not extras.
No, these were, it was a working airport.
You know, these were actual people.
- [Meg] Yeah, they were real people.
- [Kelly] Are you serious?
- [Meg] Yeah.
- In fact,
I recognize some of them.
(audience laughing)
- So, I have to say
you're both in rom-coms
that are so massively popular
that people love and adore.
So.
- I'm not, she is.
- You are.
- "Return to Me" is
like one of my favorite.
What?
(audience clapping)
So wait, what's the best time
you feel to watch a rom-com?
When do you watch like,
it's like sad music.
When do you listen to...
- When you're sick.
When you're getting over being sick.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- That's what people tell me anyway.
(David laughing)
- [Kelly] That is true.
- Yeah, like when you're recovering
and you feel like you cracked it,
and you're on the upswing.
- You need something nice, yes.
- [Meg] Kind.
- That's when I watch Doris Day.
Yeah, all those old things.
- Yes, exactly.
- [David] Really?
- You just wanna feel good?
- How about you?
When do you watch rom-com?
- That's what I do.
I watch, well,
I watch a real well-known
film called "Return to Me."`
(audience laughing)
And "You've Got Mail."
I watch all those.
When you wanna watch a rom-com,
what do you, what mood are you in?
- [Meg] Yeah, what mood?
- I don't know.
I think, here's my honest answer.
When I find one, when
I'm flipping, flipping.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- It's either "Goodfellas"
and people are gonna kill
each other, or it's a rom-com.
- I can go with that too.
I get into "The Equalizer"
whenever I'm not feeling good,
and I just wanna kick someone's ass.
- Yeah.
- It's a good movie.
- Well, it's not a rom-com, but anyway.